one of the notable Hallmarks of world
war one was the introduction of modern
technology into Warfare such technology
as radio communications airplanes tanks
motorized vehicles and high explosives
are still present on the battlefield
today however there is one weapon from
World War one that has been synonymous
with the conflict and yet has rarely
been used in Modern Warfare in this
video I'll be talking about the dark
science of mustard gas
[Music]
the first year of fighting in 1914
proved to be a challenge intense
nationalism rapid advancement in
technology and the prolonged stalemate
of trench warfare drove both sides to
seek any advantage they could get
victory was achieved by advancing and
taking as much land from the enemy as
possible different strategies were used
to break the stalemate planes were used
to bomb trenches overhead and mines were
dug below enemy trench lines filled with
explosives and then detonated however
these strategies had shortfalls trenches
were quickly dug in zigzag formations to
prevent consistent aerial bombing and
underground mines were hazardous
sometimes resulting in cave-ins costing
men and resources one solution that was
cost effective and simple to execute was
launching artillery shells filled with
toxic chemicals into Enemy Lines the
idea was deployment of chemical weapons
into enemy trenches would cause troops
to disperse and thereby weaken defenses
or they would stay and die from exposure
in either case using chemical warfare
seemed like the most effective way to
break stalemate the Germans were the
first to explore the new field of
chemical warfare and employed none other
than renowned chemist Fritz Haber to
head the chemical warfare program Habra
first relied on chlorine gas as a
chemical weapon on the night of April 22
1915 in ipra Belgium German forces
placed 6 000 steel canisters of chlorine
gas along their trench lines German
meteorologists tracked wind patterns of
the region and knew when to release the
gaseous chlorine within 10 minutes 160
tons of chlorine gas was carried into
British French and Canadian trenches
killing thousands
chlorine is a diatomic gas about two
times denser than air pale green in
color and has an odor described as a mix
of pineapple and pepper upon inhalation
it reacts with water in the lungs to
form hydrochloric acid resulting in
horrific chemical burns to the lungs
leading to Suffocation however despite
its lethality chlorine's use was
short-lived its green Haze made it easy
to see and due to its solubility in
water soldiers could protect their
airways with the rag soaked in water or
use a gas mask additionally being a gas
chlorine was carried by unexpected wind
patterns causing it to disperse too
quickly or be carried back to Friendly
trenches as happened with the British at
the Battle of lose the next choice for
Fritz Harbor was fosgene gas phosgene is
composed of two chlorine atoms bound to
a carbonyl group unlike chlorine
phosgene has no color and smells of
musty hay when inhaled vosgene disrupts
function of proteins in air sacs called
alveoli in the lungs this malfunction
approach proteins cause breakdown of
respiratory lining leading to pulmonary
edema or fluid buildup so much fluid
accumulates in the lungs that soldiers
actually drowned in their own blood
symptoms of phosgene gas poisoning
included shortness of breath vomiting
and violent coughing accompanied by
heaping up a mixture of pink and red
sputum from broken down lung tissue
however due to delayed protein reactions
effects took about 48 hours to Manifest
this was not an ideal weapon as it took
too long to incapacitate the enemy in
soldiers simply countered phosgene with
gas masks as they had done with chlorine
after several attempts in finding the
ideal chemical weapon fritzhabber
finally settled on mustard gas there
were actually two different types of
mustard gas being used during World War
One a species containing nitrogen and a
species containing sulfur duly named
nitrogen mustards and sulfur mustards in
Sulfur mustards a sulfur atom sits in
the center of the molecule flanked by
two carbon chains and two chlorine atoms
in nitrogen mustards a a nitrogen atom
is positioned in the middle attached to
three carbon chains and three chlorine
atoms in its pure State mustard gas is a
clear oily liquid with no color or smell
however when formulated for Warfare it
takes on a yellow appearance and smells
similar to horseradish mustard mustard
gas was preferred over chlorine and
phosgene gas because it existed as a
liquid with low volatility it was
unaffected by wind and not easily
identified additionally unlike phosgene
and chlorine gas which relied on
inhalation as a mechanism of injury
mustard gas only had to make contact
with the skin it was deployed via
artillery shells containing glass
bottles upon detonation the glass bottle
exploded releasing a large radius of
raining mustard gas in its mechanism of
injury mustard gas is highly lipophilic
meaning it dissolves well in the
substances high in fat human skin has a
fair amount of fat composition in the
hypodermis layer making absorption of
mustard gas very easy Once beneath the
skin about 90 percent of it is carried
away by the bloodstream and 10 stays
fixed in the local deposits what's most
Insidious of this process is it goes
mostly unnoticed it's falsely believed
that mustard gas acted similar to acid
and that once it touched the skin there
were immediate Burns this is not true
mustard gas dissolving into the skin has
very mild irritation and can go
unnoticed the actual damage is done by
its carcinogenic properties when it
damages DNA however this DNA damage
takes several hours to occur leaving the
victim clueless to the ensuing horror
different mustard gases affect DNA in
different ways nitrogen-based mustard
squeezes in between the two strands of
the DNA Helix in crosslink's DNA
nucleotides together by bonding to
nitrogen atoms on guanine nucleotides
once in the body sulfur-based mustard
gases form an unstable cyclic
intermediate called the ethylene
epicylthinium ion in this molecule the
sulfur atom is positively charged and
seeks to bind with anything that is
negatively charged consequently it also
bind to the negatively charged nitrogen
atom on guanine nucleotides in DNA in
both cases of nitrogen and sulfur-based
mustard gas the structure of DNA is
altered cells are very receptive to
changes in DNA and interprets the change
in structure as DNA damage to prevent
damaged DNA from being replicated cells
undergo apoptosis or program cell death
this causes the classic appearance of
pus-filled blisters and necrotic tissue
associated with mustard gas exposure
additionally this alteration in DNA
often leads to complications in cancer
later in life for example a 2003 study
from the Journal of Occupational and
environmental medicine found that 34 000
veterans who were exposed to sulfur
mustard used extensively during the
iran-iraq war in the 1980s suffered
numerous Health complications later in
life 42 percent had pulmonary
complications 39 ocular complications
and 24 percent had skin related
complications in a historical note
regarding mustard gas since it existed
in a liquid state soldiers often had eye
related injuries from getting splashed
when shells detonated nearby often
causing temporary or permanent blindness
this very occurrence happened to a young
Lance corporal in the German Army named
Adolf Hitler Hitler was temporarily
blinded by mustard gas during the Battle
of Eber in 1918 and took two weeks to
fully recover
despite its horrific effects the
mortality rate for mustard gas injury
during the first world war was just
between two and three percent its
Effectiveness was not in killing the
enemy but rather the psychological
trauma it instilled soldiers may think
twice about running through no man's
land that was soaked with what could be
mustard gas one could walk through a
field of mustard gas and not have any
signs of injury until several hours
later soldiers were even known to
retreat when it was deployed on the
battlefield playing into its
psychological effects to add to the
terror most countermeasures against
mustard gas were ineffective gas masks
did little to help as mustard gas did
most damage with contact on skin or
clothing being a liquid it pooled in
trenches foxholes and contaminated
groundwater it had a higher density than
water and often sank to the bottom of
Puddles making it almost impossible to
detect any rain-soaked field despite
wearing layers of clothing it penetrated
cloth wool and even leather troops
became paranoid of liquids pooling in
trenches and sleeping quarters some were
hesitant in to drink water sourced from
a well as mustard gas often leached into
the ground the goal of mustard gas was
not death but mental and physical
incapacitation and it worked extremely
well after the end of world war one
nearly all sides oppose future use of
chemical warfare due to its inhumane
effects in 1925 the Geneva protocol
prohibited the use of all chemical
weapons as they caused unneeded
suffering and often contributed to
civilian deaths despite International
opposition mustard gas would be used
during the iran-iraq war of 1980 to 1988
and the Syrian Civil War in 2012. in
both instances horrific injuries
occurred largely in civilian populations
chemical warfare is enacted as
unanimously opposed by All Nations but
unfortunately is still used in some
regions of the world despite its Horrors
it is something that Humanity will
forever be threatened by
sometimes science can be seen as
difficult foreign and even boring yet
there are times when science grabs our
attention and draws Us in yearning for
more answers often what draws a center
topics that are dark Macabre or
terrifying it's with the intention of
this video that you too were drawn in
and sought to have your questions
answered thanks for watching Dark
science